في محطه بيبدا نيو كريم ثاني اكبر منشاه
ذريه اوكرانيه بعد ذا بوليجيا رفع علم
الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه ذريه رافايل جروسي
اعلن عن توسيع نشاط وكالته في اوكرانيا
لتوفير الامان النووي في هذا البلد الذي
تعصف به الحرب
من اجل الحفاظ على عمل هذه المرافق المهمه
جدا البلد خاصه في هذه الاوقات الصعبه
مرافق نوويه اوكرانيه بينها تشرنوبل الذي
اغلق بعد كارثه
1986 كارثه لا يامل احد ان تتكرر ولا سيما
في محطه
للسيطره الروسيه والقريبه من خطوط
المواجهه فقبل يومين فقط استهدفت مدينه
ذاتوريجيا التي مازالت بيدي سلطات
الاوكرانيه بقصف صاروخيه
حدث كل شيء في اجزاء من الثانيه لم نفهم
ما جرى لم تطلق لا سفيره انذار ولا تحذيرا
الجانب الروسي قال ان ضربات حول زبوريجيا
كانت تستهدف معدات عسكريه اوكرانيه
لمنع كارثه نوويه يوجد مفتشون وكاله
الدوليه بشكل دائم في المحطه العملاقه منذ
ايلول سبتمبر الماضي ومن ذلك الحين تتفاوض
الوكاله مع سلطات الامر الواقع الروسيه في
زوريجيا لترسيم منطقه امنيه منزوعه السلاح
حول المحطه